[Music]
there is no let up the cubicles here at
the emergency department in warrington
were full hours ago
[Music]
new arrivals wait in whatever space is
left
[Music]
liam was admitted this morning after he
was in a car crash
it's late afternoon now and he's still
waiting in the nurses station until this
space on a ward
came back at the ct scan and said i've
got a bruised longer left lung he's left
long
for the medics the day blurs into a
constant rush making sure everyone gets
treatment
eventually the last hour we've had um
two trauma calls we've had very sick
patients in cardiac arrest and we've
also had two covered positive standbys
so that's typical of what we're seeing
now and what we have seen over the last
couple of months
this is just a snapshot of the stresses
weighing down on one emergency
department but it is a similar picture
in many places across the country
this is where the ambulances come in as
you can see it is extremely busy now on
a normal day
if they're treating 50 patients at any
one time it's considered busy
at the moment there are more than a
hundred you see people lined up in the
corridors waiting to be treated and the
fear is as the weather gets colder the
situation will get even worse
in a cubicle waiting patiently we see
ben aston he arrived with chest pains
hours ago
he came here because he couldn't get an
appointment with his gp
i understand what the situation's going
on with covert and things like that and
patients being socially distanced and
you can't have family sitting in the
waiting room with you you're more or
less on your own
it is hard
increasingly when one part of the nhs
isn't coping it's accident an emergency
that's taking the strain
there is a large amount um that
traditionally could have been seen in
primary care but at the same time our
colleagues are seeing a lot of things
that could also have been seen in
secondary care
or if they'd had their routine
investigation surgery
waiting times from a e to a ward are now
longer than ever and it is particularly
bad here patients waiting more than
eight hours
70 percent longer than the national
average
the pressures of winter and what feels
like an endless pandemic are now acute
we always say if you become overwhelmed
your resource becomes overwhelmed you
declare a major instance
it almost feels like we're always right
on the edge of a major incident so you
might say why don't you declare one well
the reality is we'd be doing it every
day
how are you feeling today elsewhere the
pressure is just as great on this ward
they're seeing an uptick in respiratory
illnesses
but they're also concerned about the new
variants omicron there's a very
difficult mix of
coverage still going on
uh new variants coming which we which
keeps us on our toes
and uh our immense winter pressures
mixed in with other respiratory
illnesses
so yeah that's a it's a really it's a
really hard place to be right now
no one here knows what will happen over
the next few weeks and months but as
winter begins it's clear the healthcare
system
is already struggling
alex rossi sky news
warrington